sponsored by step finance your go
to d5 portfolio manager on solana
luno if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys anna welcome back to the lehigh offense
show so as always it is powered by the vc firm
icon plus capital and it is sponsored by blockfi
who offer really exciting interest rates so i've
left a link for you in the comments and in
the description so check that out so joining
me today we have morgan harper former consumer
protection attorney at the consumer financial
protection bureau and current candidate for u.s
senate in ohio let's bring her in morgan great to
meet you how are you good how are you thanks for
having me yeah thank you so much for coming on
um it's always so exciting to um you know speak
to people who are involved in politics that are um
talking about bitcoin so before we get into all
of this um for those that don't know you could
you please give us some background about you um
you know where you're from and where you grew up
yeah for sure so i am originally from columbus
ohio which is where i am now i was born
at the ohio state university hospital probably
meaningless to you but very important if anyone
is listening who's in ohio and uh and was given up
for adoption and i lived in a foster home when i
was a baby and then was adopted and raised by
my mom who worked in the public school system
and you know like a lot of folks went through a
lot and i just had some early life experiences
that showed me the importance of having even one
parent with a stable job and you know the level
of financial vulnerability that we all could be
subject to overnight and that put me on this track
to figure out what's going on what is this and it
led me to public policy and eventually politics
so that's such an interesting um background and
upbringing i have to just ask you about that so
how important you know you said it's
so important to have that one stable
parent um you know so how were you able with
such a i guess difficult start able to you know
lift yourself up and be you know the candidate for
ohio well my mom is pretty incredible she's 78 now
and still lives on the east side of columbus and
um and you know she had when i say a stable job
and she worked in the public school system when
she had to take time off to be able to run and get
us somewhere or go to a doctor's appointment or
a legal appointment when things were really going
down for us and my parents were going through this
crazy divorce she knew that she would be okay that
she would still have that job that she had some
time off and you know she wasn't in a union and
that that mattered uh and you know i think what
we're seeing so much now is there's not a lot of
breathing room for folks but that was absolutely
the story of what allowed us to get through and
then you know and also i would point to a strong
community which consists of people who have the
ability and bandwidth to look out for others not
just focus on themselves you know when we couldn't
make daycare payments that we got an extra couple
weeks when we had to figure out how to get into
you know a different housing situation that we
had a neighbor that allowed us to move in for a
few months so that's that's the foundation
of what put me in a position to be able to
get scholarships to go to first you know a fancy
private school here in central ohio and then
eventually to places like princeton university
stanford law school it's it doesn't just happen
and you know of course a lot of individual effort
but lots of different people around me that put
me in the position to make that happen that's
such an interesting story um but you mentioned
multiple times that you plan to only run for two
terms so why are you so passionate about that
i'm really passionate about that because
i've been in the belly of the beast i've
been in washington dc so you know i first worked
after college at the federal trade commission
which is a federal agency that regulates
consumer protection competition policy
and uh and i was i was really turned off from
that experience i just didn't feel like folks were
really moving with urgency solve problems which
is the whole reason why i want to be in government
because if you're not trying to solve problems
like what are you doing you could just be you know
in other sectors trying to make money whatever
and um and it wasn't until you know i got to
the consumer financial protection bureau and
really saw that government can do things cans can
solve problems for people can really be efficient
data driven all of that that i really started
to believe again and what government could be um
and you know and that that was a really important
milestone for me to be able to just realize
the power the power of being in public policy
you've spoken previously i'm sorry i just actually
get to answer your questions sorry about going
so anyway so once i was there though i saw that
we could be doing even more in public policy if
we actually had politicians that were on the side
of getting things done and yeah you know for me
i was able to see in congress just how much the
limitations were people who weren't that focused
on solving problems who had been corrupted
by money and taking you know direct donations
for people bribes some might say and instead of
actually moving with that urgency that i was so
focused on that i found in my colleagues at bfpb
we're kind of slowing things down and you know a
lot of times i think people look for well what
was the vote what was the vote that showed that
they were corrupt or had sold or sold us out or
whatever but in washington a lot of things happen
before you even get to the point of having a
vote and in fact the goal of a lot of the money
in politics is to make sure that things don't go
up for a vote so there is no accountability and
it's all the backroom conversations and meeting
with lobbyists that slows the process down and
prevents anything from changing and so you know
in seeing that up close that's why one i've made
a commitment to not take corporate money but then
also in order to restore trust in our institutions
to ensure that you stay focused on serving people
i also am very committed to only serving two terms
absolute necessity in my view to be able to get
our institutions back on track you said that a
lot of the money um is to make sure that nothing
is actually done and not much actually does get
through why do you think that's the case why do
i think people don't want anything to get done or
why does it take money to do that why do you
think that they don't want to get things done
well because what we have right now
and i do think we're living through
uh what's a bit of the the end end of time so
to speak of having 40 years of really opening
up the floodgates for money to enter politics
that has enabled our our institutions like us
congress to be captured and then allows the
folks that can fund that capture which are
ultra ultra wealthy and very very very large
corporations to then secure their dominance
of our economy and make it difficult for
small medium-sized businesses to compete
for workers to really have an advantage when
negotiating for wages all of this and so
it's a it's a pretty clear plan to you know so
distrust in in the political process that then
lays the groundwork for economic gains
for a very small slice of the population
speaking of um transparency and understanding
um you know more about these political donations
you talked previously about issues to do with
campaign finance and the ability for corporations
to essentially donate directly to politicians
so how would we then fix that and where for you
does blockchain technology come in well how we fix
it is i mean there there are a couple of options
and you know ideally we would have legislation
campaign finance reform certainly that has been
introduced in in congress now to do that and it
would be great if we had functioning institutions
that could pass things that would restore uh
credibility to a lot of our institutions but
it's it's not happening and i i have to be honest
i'm not i'm not that optimistic about legislation
that would change campaign finance laws uh getting
through right now just based on what the dynamics
are politically in congress and i do you know i
wish that we didn't have barriers things like the
filibuster here in our system that prevent that
from happening but that's just what it is and so
in the meantime i think it's really essential that
we have individuals candidates and then eventually
folks who become elected officials like we started
to see in the last few years who are making this
commitment on their own we don't need to wait for
laws to pass to know what the right thing is to do
and we could just have people who decide
to do the right thing and then that changes
the whole political calculus of what the
public finds acceptable and i think that
unfortunately is is our best route right now
and the most efficient route and you see it
changing i mean when i first ran for office a
couple of years ago and i said you know i'm not
taking corporate pac money i mean people knew
what it was or what it means to be sold out to
large corporations and all that but there wasn't a
a really great understanding of pacs and the fact
that we have politicians who are just directly
taking money from the people that are supposed
to be regulating and passing legislation to
apply to and you know one one question that
really stuck with me and and really informed
just how i've spent the last couple of years and
open and being open to what it's going to take to
fix this is you know someone said at some point
well morgan you know you're critiquing all this
corporate money in politics but you know you also
have people who donate to your campaign who live
out of state what's the difference and i was i was
a bit shocked you know i always try to lead with
empathy and understanding for everybody's coming
up this stuff from a different place but wow
because if if we have people who don't understand
what the difference is between an individual who's
giving me of their you know full voting money to
my campaign and att for example who is giving ten
thousand dollars to a sitting elected official
then we as a public have a misunderstanding
of power and how it works in this country
how it is wielded through our government and how
it is tried to use is used against us to prevent
most of us from being more financially stable
and that is a big problem and so by having
individual people candidates and then eventually
elected officials as well who are educating the
public by making this commitment uh that can have
a big impact then about what criteria folks use
to then vote and choose elected officials and i've
seen that even over a couple of years just focused
on ohio there's a much better understanding of the
influence of money and politics and the desire to
do something to stop it yeah i definitely think
um the public this is sort of a global thing
desires more transparency right now and i think
people definitely feel that they've been lied to
um but you made this really long thread a
couple of months ago which is actually how
um i came across you because i'm british
so i'm not directly involved in american
politics um but the thread was about bitcoin
and the importance of decentralization so
can you explain to me your view on bitcoin um and
i guess really just you know what drew you to it
so i first started hearing about bitcoin
crypto blockchain technology when i was at
the consumer financial protection bureau and
you know i started at the the bureau in 2013
and so it was now time flies we were talking
about that uh gray hairs are coming that was
almost ten years ago and uh you know and it was
it wasn't part of my core portfolio but they
were just people who were meeting with folks that
were in the industry excited about the technology
and coming back and you know sharing stories about
that so sort of passively started to hear about
it then and you know it's been interesting
over the last year just having more people
i was having more people in ohio who were
talking to me about how they were excited about
it how they were you know investing how they were
thinking about applications of blockchain and then
also you know creatives looking at nfts and what
that could all mean as well uh and so you know
it seemed like wow okay this has gotten to a much
broader uh set of folks this isn't just some niche
thing as much anymore and i need to be paying
closer attention to it as well as someone who
seeks to represent people in this state uh and
so you know started just reading more about it
talking to more people about it and wanted to
put out a statement that just says hey look i
mean i am all about trying to decentralize power
and control and promote economic freedom among
as many people as possible and like we were just
talking about i mean i think that is what a lot of
the corruption has limited our ability to be more
economically free and so if this sector has the
ability to broaden opportunity this is something
that we need to be talking about paying attention
to learning listening uh and and it's been cool
i mean since we posted that i've engaged with so
many more people um in this area hearing stories
people reached out to me in ohio who had never
heard about the campaign or anything that i stood
for that were messaging me on facebook like oh so
cool to see someone who's running for office who's
talking about this um and and that was great that
was great because you know we we've been living
through this era where i think there's a lot of
you know division polarization no you you're on
this side i'm on that side and i want to i want to
try to bring in as many people as possible and and
be open to different perspectives that folks have
yeah i mean speaking of um the division and the
polarization a lot of people in the community
in the crypto community in bitcoin in particular
would say that bitcoin is apolitical um whereas
ted cruz um a couple of weeks ago i think it was
a cpac in florida made this really loud statement
saying that the left don't like bitcoin because
they can't control it um and there's there's truth
and there's also not truth to that you know
it's quite it's quite a broad statement um so
you know where do you stand on that you're
obviously a democrat and you're interested
in bitcoin so what do you think about you know
the left at the quote unquote not being able to
control that yeah i mean first of all let's be
clear ted cruz and and this isn't and this is
really important and this is something that i have
come to after having a lot of conversations with
people in this space over you know the last few
months is we we cannot just focus on one thing
that people talk about first of all i don't know
what it means to speak for the left okay i don't
know i don't know what that means i don't know
who you're talking about but i do know that ted
cruz is often not talking about anything that's
about advancing most people in this country doing
better than the day before okay and and that's not
a party thing and and that's what we really need
to be focused on is like we're we're moving into
this era and i do think that this is something
you know when you say that a lot of folks that
are into bitcoin identify as apolitical well i
do think there's something to that where we're in
we're moving into this era where people are sick
of the politics they're sick of parties they're
very skeptical of status quo and leadership and
rightly so in many cases but folks like ted
cruz are not advancing us to a higher place
in my view and that isn't my view as a democrat
that's my view as morgan harper who lives in this
country and is watching what's going on and i
don't hear any ideas so just because and this is
the real danger and i have talked to people in the
community who identify as single-issue voters well
more power to you i mean there's a lot of there's
a lot of privilege built into being a single issue
voter i would say right now but even if that even
if that's where you're coming from i mean look at
what some of the other things that these folks
are saying people like ted cruz people like you
know josh mandel who's running in the republican
primary on this side it's it can't be enough that
they just put the avatar up on their twitter right
it's like what else are these people standing for
and trust and believe it is not about expanding
freedom okay so we need to be a little bit more
nuanced and analytical about what who we're
supporting and why and what else they stand for
i would say that would be one of my my charges to
the community is got to be more responsible than
that yeah i think you know i i'm also personally
really skeptical about politicians that you know
come out saying that they they support bitcoin and
then you look at their track record and it sort of
just isn't aligned with you know freedom and and
all sorts of things you know they could say they
like bitcoin and then two minutes later they ban
bitcoin mining you know so it is it is weird and
we we do have to see women being able to do what
they want with their bodies for example right
it's like i don't know i mean i don't want to get
too political but this is the reality that we're
living in here it's like these are people that
want to try to tell kids what they can learn okay
they want to also prevent us from being able to
manage our own reproductive rights decisions and
just because they like bitcoin then we're going to
ignore all that other stuff that doesn't sit well
with me at all i understand i think it's worth you
know looking at the the individual's entire voting
history and you know checking if it is congruent
with what they're what they're supporting um
but i think you know right now america is at
this kind of um crossroads you know like is
is america going to be at the forefront of this
revolution or um like it should be um or is it
gonna be left behind and you know people were very
concerned over um the uh biden's executive order
so i'd love to hear your take on it concerned
about a concern before it came out or after
i think both well i can speak about the after bit
that's more to do with cbdc's which we can discuss
um but they were more concerned about essentially
just stifling innovation and you know we could
talk about elizabeth warren and her approach
afterwards but i'd like to know whether you think
you know his executive order is positive and where
america is going to be moving forward is it going
to be left behind yeah well i i actually saw it as
a positive thing because to me what it was is one
acknowledging that the space has grown and there's
a lot of interest in it and that there needs to be
some attention paid by the federal government to
be able to explore what regulation could look like
what innovation should look like and how to best
foster innovation and also balance you know and
mitigate any risk uh that to me is a validation
of just the growth of the space and and then you
know the worst case scenario to me is folks just
ignoring it all together and then continuing to
dash it without necessarily having
full information so i don't i took
it i took it as a positive and then you know
looking through the order what the charge is
is to different agencies so the whole of
government approach having different agencies
collect data get information that'll probably lead
i imagine to you know further hearings that will
happen on the hill that there could be meetings
that happen that are organized directly by the
executive branch by the white house and uh and
further educating people about you know what the
opportunities are so i took it i took it as a
positive yeah you're obviously you know part of
this next generation of politicians but i just
from what i can see the current administration
don't get it you know there was
that shocking video that came out
of elizabeth warren essentially refusing to
listen to somebody explaining why bitcoin
isn't the best when it comes to um you know
elicit activity so you know my question to you
is you know why don't they understand it and do
you think that perhaps they are choosing to ignore
it i mean it's hard for me to speak for others and
you know where they're where they're coming from
and and why they're saying certain things but you
know i i have found and this sometimes can happen
in in washington that there sometimes can be a
very a reflexive reaction and then once there's
been a generally held view then other people just
start sharing that generally held view and i do
think it's important or i feel a responsibility as
someone who is seeking to lead to engage collect
more information you know like i was saying before
be open-minded and then form for my own my own
opinions and and i think in in especially
when you're looking at you know regulation
and what that might look like and that that was
what i learned being at the consumer financial
protection bureau is you engage with all sorts of
folks from industry you engage with people from
advocacy community and you come up with what's
the best policy and i i have a similar approach
here i think you know one thing i would point to
though where there probably is the source of some
skepticism by a lot of people you know coming from
the consumer protection space is there's there's
this sense that you know with the fintech and with
a lot of the the financial technology companies
that emerged and this was really growing you know
when i was at cfpb and certainly has continued to
grow after uh that folks were sold kind of a a
fake bill of goods so to speak right you know
that there's going to be this revolution that's
coming and it's really going to help and change be
a game changer for the unbanked and be much more
equitable than the traditional banking system and
it doesn't seem like that has really proven to be
true i mean we see a lot of replication of some of
the dynamics that people could label i believe
rightly as predatory dynamics that happen in
the traditional banking system that also happen
when you have fintech companies that are just
layering on top of the existing system and so
i think that it is incumbent on people who you
know really believe in in bitcoin and crypto in
blockchain technology in the possibilities to even
when it gets frustrating continue to to educate
people and engage and you can't just shut down
and i think that you know the same responsibility
for folks who are in elected office uh we we also
or seek to be there you know we we can't shut
down either we need to be able to continue to
learn and come up with what's the best approach to
protect the innovation and have the us be a leader
on it and then also mitigate the risks so how do
we bridge the gap between those who are currently
setting legislation on on all of this who
sort of refuse to have an open mind about it
um so how do we how do we bridge that gap of
education and sort of you know explaining it
in a balanced way that you know we understand
you know regulation might be necessary um
but let's like understand correctly what we're
what we're regulating essentially like how do you
bridge that educational gap well you know i think
having platforms like this that are continuing to
be a source of information for people that are
a little bit outside of the traditional media is
really helpful uh and because well i've seen and
it's been interesting i mean even over the last
couple of months and you know you're getting at
this one you're mentioning ted cruz that there's
this view oh the left is anti anti-olive right
right and i actually you know found just through
engaging a little bit and then having a couple
of examples of people who are willing to talk
about it that that narrative has changed now and
that's that's broken down a little bit because
you see examples of people who are on the more
progressive side of things who are democrats
again who knows what we're talking about when we
say the left um but you know who are willing to
who are willing to talk about it and so that that
changes you know the whole uh landscape and so
that's important to have platforms like this but
then also you know when you look specifically at
institutions of government uh that there there
are different branches and they're different
branches for a reason so yeah okay you know
hitting some frustrating moments with particular
people in congress well there's this whole white
house that you know has also moved forward with
this executive order and being able to apply more
resources there and then they also will have a
separate platform for how to continue to engage
the public and that leads to things like i've
seen even now in more you know mainstream media
publications that starting to cover it in a more
balanced way and what does balance mean balance to
me and this should be the goal of all journalism
in my view though it's not always the case is
presenting information and letting readers decide
for themselves not so much editorializing and i
have seen you know especially over the last month
just more more coverage that seems to me to have
a much different tone much more of an educational
tone and less of a no no no no like here's why
you shouldn't even be paying attention to this
yeah i think um the community feel not to speak
on behalf of the community but i know that we have
seen a lot of um media which is just so incorrect
you know whether it be about like uh bitcoin's
energy consumption um you know there's a total
disregard for actually how the renewable energy
could actually be better for the environment um
you know there's a total disregard for a lot of
facts so i know that that would be appreciated
if we started to see you know a lot more of a
factual and honest conversation um so so do you
think we could get america would get to a point
whereby you know there is too much regulation
um and innovation begins to move elsewhere
it's certainly possible it's certainly possible
i mean well you know i couldn't say that now
we're at a place where there's too much regulation
but now we're at a place where it's just unknown
where we're going from here and like i said i
mean to me the executive order was a step in
the right direction of gathering more information
before moving too quickly in one direction or the
other that's good that's a good starting place
um yeah always always the possibility that you
know there's a lot of regulation in an industry
that isn't necessarily then allowing the industry
to grow but it doesn't appear that that's where
we're at right now and i think by continuing to
educate engage and in this the other thing i
would point to is because this is a question
i get a lot is you know what are the specific
use cases it seems like and sometimes i'll be
real with you i mean sometimes people struggle to
come up with those of what are the use cases that
make this you know so much better than what's come
before in traditional banking and look you know i
i am very open about critiquing a lot of
things in the traditional financial system
but then you know being able to point
to these are the specific ways in which
this is an improvement and not a replication
of you know what already is not working in the
traditional space and like i said i mean i think
that is that's what breeds some of the skepticism
because people feel like that is what happened
with a lot of the promises of fintech for example
how do you speak to people in ohio about it when
they ask you about it so usually it's uh people so
most often it's people asking me why am i talking
about it at all uh and and you know like we like
we just discussed i mean i i tell people it's
like hey look we have a lot of people in our
state that are pretty interested in this and
different communities different sectors um i
sometimes i find that people are surprised to
learn that you know folks are interested in the
creative sectors and how that might allow people
to be able to capture more of the ownership and
financial benefits of what you know the work
that they're doing so there's a lot of there's
a lack of understanding but usually now because
i've been speaking out about it more i'm getting
a lot of questions on why are you talking about
this at all uh and and that's interesting because
you know i got more of those i would say a couple
of months ago but now as there's more media
coverage of the topic generally people are like
oh interesting you were already kind of talking
about this and now it's moving forward and the
environmental thing is a big big issue and so you
know i don't want to at all minimize that i mean
that is something that when folks are asking me
about it they bring up very specifically about you
know how isn't this an environmental disaster and
how are we going to be able to possibly you know
avoid don't we already have so many issues with
the climate um but you know being able to tell
people hey you know that's one of the questions i
have to the community and i i'm always looking for
more information about like okay if we're going to
be moving forward with this how do we mitigate
you know bad environmental outcomes that has
to be a priority as we're looking at you know
colossal damage coming from the climate crisis
what's your answer for that yeah i think it's a
fair question my answer is energy arbitrage so
the fact so for the very first time and i feel
so i it's so hard to explain this but i'm going
to give it a go so for the very first time we're
actually seeing the decentralization of energy
so you don't have to um you know burn
fossil fuels or do whatever you do to
you know get that energy in certain parts of the
world you can use renewable energy from anywhere
so you know whether it's um whether it's solar
energy geothermal energy um you know hydroelectric
you can go to places where there's unused energy
a lot of the times people build um you know like
these these huge power plants and they're often
built for the um energy usage of tomorrow meaning
in 20 years time so now you have all of that
infrastructure that's built and it's just wasted
whereas miners because it's decentralized can mine
from anywhere in the world so an amazing example
is in el salvador so they're literally using the
geothermal energy from volcanoes with zero co2
emissions to mine and to secure the network so
it's energy arbitrage so it can be done anywhere
so and then also because the energy is cheaper
because either it's renewable or it's wasted
and much of the time it's wasted um miners are
actually incentivized to seek out that energy
does that make sense because because it is so
expensive to secure the network they are literally
incentivized to secure out greener energy because
it's going to be cheaper um and never before are
you seeing you know the decentralization of that
energy so energy arbitrage i think it's great
yeah yeah yeah and that that is what i've heard
from other people too and yeah and we just have to
continue to show examples of it i think for folks
to really get that and and and mitigate you know
what is a really big fear is people are really
concerned about the climate crisis rightly and
knowing how this isn't going to be perpetuating
the same dynamics i think is really important
yeah absolutely i just i i wish that we could
have that nuanced conversation um because people
always talk about it you know it's the end of the
world but but it's not you know it's literally
better for the environment because you know
with the traditional banking system and with
gold and the the entire um you know in the gold
industry you literally can't do that there's no
energy arbitrage um so you know for me it's just
quite obvious and i just hope that you know we can
have these honest conversations um but we'll get
there we'll get there um but there was a part
of the executive order which spoke about cbdc's
central bank digital currencies and i don't know
you know if you're involved in that much but
i just you know wanted to get your opinion
on central bank digital currencies because for
me personally i think they're quite dangerous
yeah i i haven't delved as much into that
so i would probably be more in question mode
there yeah what dangerous why so central
bank digital currencies would basically be
like a cryptocurrency um that is controlled
by the government so it would be uh on a
block on blockchain technology but the money is
programmable that's what concerns me personally
um so you know i i have these concerns that
if there is this climate crisis and things are
getting worse we could all be using the cbdc and
you know you go fill up your car and it's refused
just because you've reached your pollution
limit because you know we're in this energy
crisis and now that money that you have that
that is yours isn't really yours so it can be
programmed to do certain things and even you know
even there's a lot of um we're living in this time
of disinformation and misinformation and what was
misinformation last week is now fact this week um
you know so facts are changing um so there's also
concern you know that if you if you retweeted a
certain person on twitter and you liked a certain
post or you went to a certain protest you know
your money could be frozen and we saw that happen
in canada so with cbdc's essentially it's just
more efficient for the government to have that
control of your money yeah yeah no and i mean
this is definitely something i've heard from a lot
of people you know in the community is concerned
about you know a lot of government control and
and not having transparency over you know how some
regulations could change i think that's fair and
um and you know but the counter to that is often
okay but then we can't have people that are
just operating totally outside of the system
and there's no transparency and that's where i
think there is a lack of understanding is you know
they're in in its best form my my understanding is
that you would have a lot of transparent you have
a lot of transparency on what's happening in the
ledger and who's doing what and um and so that's
less of a concern but yeah i hear it i hear what
you're saying haven't gone deeply into that but
yeah understood yeah so with with the ledger
i think i love the idea of transparency but
my concern and also be good to get your opinion on
this um would be that it would be one way so a lot
of people feel like you know they're giving all
these these dollars in taxes and all this stuff
and they're not really seeing where that's where
that money's going you know whether it's going to
fund wars whether it's going you know to different
big corporations um so with a cbdc it would be
sort of a one-way relationship um you know so
government would see would see every single
transaction that the population have done but we
wouldn't see where that money goes so do you think
and i tweeted this yesterday we could ever live in
a society or in a world whereby you know taxes are
transparent on a ledger so we can see from start
to finish exactly where those dollars are going
i think that would be really cool and it should be
some expectation of what government is i mean on
the the federal level is probably a challenging
place to start with that but definitely
you know at the more local level for example i i i
actually don't see why that couldn't that couldn't
happen now free of a even having a ledger right
is being able to demand transparency from our
government on where money is going and then what
we got from that expenditure seems very basic
right and when we get at you know what we were
talking about earlier the lack of trust in our
institutions i do think it's because people have
no idea what's going on i mean for example i grew
up around people yeah i got the scholarship to go
nice private school a lot of people were pretty
conservative and there was this view it's like
federal government every dollar waste of money
that's why i don't want higher taxes that's
why i want to be able to give to charity rather
than having my money go to social services all of
that and i do think that you know some of that is
those are people that just philosophically
do not believe in government at all
okay i'm not one of those people i think it has
a lot to do with for many people about just not
trusting and having transparency around what
we're doing with this money and so yeah i mean
i i am all about transparency i am all about
accountability those are two of the guiding
principles of my entire life and uh and certainly
what i think we need more of in government and um
but yeah but i guess you know and not to not
to turn a lot of questions back on you but
i am kind of curious about yeah because what like
what would be your response though to couldn't
that transparency happen even free of a ledger for
example like couldn't you just have for example
you know the president a mayor that's just gonna
say here's the money we spent here's what it went
towards here's what didn't work out about that
that money and we're going to change you know
moving forward next year for this reason something
like that but that would require putting your
trust in that centralized body right whether
it's the mayor whether it's the government um
and i think we've just been proven time and time
again that we just can't do that and i think
the whole narrative surrounding crypto and
decentralization and particularly bitcoin
actually is so that you don't have to trust
a third party to you know potentially um
you know doctor those documents you know make
them false change something um and so i think
the only way to truly understand where that
tax money is going and how it's being spent
is to have that decentralized ledger um where we
can see exactly what's happened but i just i can't
imagine i can't imagine a world where that would
ever be the case i think if if they sort of say
you know it's a national security issue we're not
allowed to know yeah that's why that's what you
know well it's really cool to talk to you about
this uh that's why i actually think starting with
a local government might be more interesting there
because yes yeah you take away the life or death
stakes of everything that's going on it's like
okay well now we're talking about collecting the
trash and making sure that you know rec centers
are opened on time and this kind of thing and you
know moderate stakes at best right okay um and so
that seems like a place to really experiment with
these things and make the case and and i don't
know i found once you start opening people up
to transparency and accountability nobody wants
to go back from that right and so being able to
yeah you know apply the ledger in that way could
be because i agree with you i mean right now
it's a rare politician that even agrees to not
take any corporate money and agree to term limits
and self-imposing them but uh so you probably do
need some mechanism to drive that transparency
and accountability that's not dependent on an
individual committing to it but i would love to
believe that we're working towards a world that we
have people in elected office that just want that
anyway you know for for the good of the people uh
but yeah and not hollyannish that we have a long
way to go there well you make an interesting point
you can do this on a state level because it's not
life and death you know you don't have the entire
you know establishment you know that you could
that could go wrong um so on a state level how
do you plan i guess to start implementing these
ideas well you know so i'm running for the federal
seat um and so i haven't you know in terms of on
the campaign or anything i wouldn't say that
we've we've done anything to apply it directly
but you know it is it is interesting to just
be able to have these conversations with people
as we build towards what i hope is you know a
better future where people really trust government
and so you know it's interesting to think about
for example i don't know once elect and i'm just
totally brainstorming here with you like no i
love it i love it um but you know for example
as a us senator you get a budget you get to
run your constituent services office and your
your office in you know in washington legislative
office and having full transparency around
what that budget's going towards and applying you
know the use of a ledger or something in that way
i don't know that that could be interesting and so
the public knows exactly well this is how much i
got to serve you and this is what it went towards
and and this couldn't happen i love that i love
that idea i mean one thing that you know i've
talked about a lot traveling around the state
that's short of that but getting at the
same theme to me is you know hosting a lot
of town halls and keeping people engaged
on what's going on i get the question of
okay well morgan you know you say your grassroots
you're going to be different but what does that
look like in a day-to-day way you know as a as
a grassroots no corporate money u.s senator and
i point to things like that you know the typical
model is you get elected you see a lot of somebody
as they're trying to get elected once you're
elected it's like bye bye see you in the next six
years but i want to maintain that connectivity
and i do think it would be interesting to
to consider how you apply the technology to
feed into that you know consistent communication
with the electorate and also transparency
around what the resources that are going
to one individual center senator are are going
towards and you know how they're getting applied
yeah i think it'd be fascinating and you know if
you're able to to do that and lead that um i know
i can there'd just be so much support behind you
because people do they feel entirely disillusioned
um you know even here in the uk it's just just
globally um people it is it is global yeah and and
it's i mean it it's heartbreaking in a lot of ways
and you know i had a conversation with someone who
is in in my network very skeptical of all of this
um and you know we talked through um just how many
people i i engage with who are excited about it
and and i think it was a humbling moment for that
person because what it's getting at is what you're
saying it's like people are distrustful people are
disillusioned if we agree that it's rational that
people find themselves in that place then we can't
just cut off the mechanisms that folks are finding
to be a gateway to something better it's incumbent
on us to both fix the institutions and have better
people who are inhabiting them who are more honest
who invite that transparency and accountability
but then also recognize you know in the meantime
this is providing value to people and and there's
and there's ways for you know how the technology
develops here to maybe feed into that larger goal
as well so more than anything that's where i land
on hey look disillusionment rational in my view we
have been completely misled by a lot of people who
are supposed to be looking out for us they have
been bought off and are not not looking out for us
there's a lot of awareness about that some
people are capitalizing on that awareness
and trying to further mislead people and take
us down an even worse route but i individually
am offering myself as somebody who's like hey
agree with you honest about what's gone wrong
but really really committed to building towards a
better future that is more free for all of us and
i and when i say all of us i truly mean all of us
and that's something that i think we need to see
not just here in ohio not just across the united
states but to your point globally globally and
we need to and we need to move forward on
these things as quickly as we can because
in a lot of ways we're running out of time yeah
no i totally agree with you and to what extent
do you think that this is going to become you know
either a partisan or bipartisan issue um you know
and it's going to be one of those one of those
one of those defining issues whether a bit like
you know guns abortion and lgbt rights things like
that you know i had someone who mentioned to me
uh that they thought it was going down that route
and i hope not i hope not yeah and you know and
even on those other issues that you named that
have become so polarizing i'm trying to chart out
you know a different a different path here where
it acknowledges different viewpoints but then also
doesn't allow us to be totally captured in
whatever corner we find ourselves in because
you know you know what that feeds into the
overall disillusionment and then we're just yes
we're repeating the same cycle and so you know
like take for example something like guns that
now is presented as this highly partisan issue
it's like well you know the reality of that
is that there are a lot of people who
probably identify as democrats who also
really love owning guns okay and so the issue
is not gun ownership the issue is that we've had
organizations like the nra through a lot of money
that has infiltrated washington dc that has made
people think that this is a yes or no issue when
in fact the middle is much grayer and what most
people agree on is that we need to be doing
things to prevent accidents suicides homicides
involving guns and so similarly here i mean to
me the reality is much more gray than you would
necessarily get especially from you know when i
first started really engaging in this space and
what media would cover is that i don't know when
i'm not when i'm beyond the political pundit stage
average person is kind of like one i have no idea
what this is at all or two it's like oh i've heard
some things about that that's interesting or three
hey i know a lot about this i'm really excited
about it and i don't care what all these people
are saying and that that to me is then again as
a leader responsibility as a leader is to create
space for all of those folks to engage learn and
then come up with what we want to we want to see
moving forward yeah and you made an interesting
point earlier as well when you spoke about that um
you know talking about disillusionment and sort of
but the wrong thing when people see an alternative
to the current system banning that is just the
worst thing you can do you know it feeds into
it yeah i i yeah i think that's right and also
it it does another way that it feeds into it is
it seems to disregard what's not working about
the existing system and this is something you know
i pointed to in in that thread or maybe the one we
did after of you know take for example something
like overdraft fees overdraft fees are totally
messed up they are predatory there is no reason
why with existing technology that banks can't know
when you have money and when you don't and if
you don't have money they can just reject the
transaction instead of charging people who don't
have a lot of money 30 or whatever right and so
yeah and then what once people see it's like
oh so suddenly you're going to be all know
on this thing but that implicitly
makes it seem like everything is
completely fine in what we've got further loss
of credibility and and so yeah honesty i think
with this moment that we're living through
and it's a prolonged moment and 2020 as
we can call it is just a real cry for honesty
and more transparency and more accountability
and it'll it's incumbent on us that you
know those of us who really believe in that
living up to that and then finding each other
as quickly as we can like i said because
the alternative the alternative is dark and i do
believe that we can have you know not to get too
hokey here but a brighter future but it's not a
guarantee but it starts with honesty no i agree
the honesty transparency um it's the best way
forward um so just finally then off topic is a
side topic because i'm still really fascinated
by um the difficult like i love i love the kind
of story which is a difficult upbringing and then
you know make something amazing i i really love
that and i value it a lot because i'm i'm big on
personal responsibility and i'm big on you know
sort of saying it doesn't matter what happened i
can still make something great so what would be um
i guess some sort of words of wisdom or you know
three tips just for people who are trying to build
something i know i know it's cliche but it is
nice um people who are trying to build something
yeah yeah yeah people who are trying to
build something and they sort of feel you
know disillusioned with everything that's
going on um and what can they do right now
especially with inflation skyrocketing and
the way the world is right now yeah yeah
well i i just encourage people to to leap i
mean you know i i got into this politics thing
and everybody you know the the political punditry
class here at ohio was kind of like who is she
she's going nowhere all of that but what what
people like that misunderstand is that folks that
are just regular people are very aware of what's
going on and are fed up and and then if you give
some if you present to the public something that
is authentic and that they can believe in i find
people rally behind it and so you know i i had
to learn this because you know one of the other
uh outcomes from my upbringing which you know
really put me in a position to succeed in a very
superficial good degree sort of way is it can make
you a little bit nervous about slipping behind
again right and never wanting to feel financially
vulnerable and being a little more risk-averse
and you know that i i don't want anyone to think
that we need to be leaping we need to be swinging
big we need to be confident and there are a lot
of people who when you take those swings will
line up behind you and as long as you're being
authentic in what you're trying to do so you know
i think we have a system right now and this is one
of the policy issues that i'm really focused on
is rewards you know a select few from feeling that
they're comfortable to take those risks and not
have any you know negative repercussions from them
and i want to broaden you know broaden economic
opportunity broaden the ability for a lot of us
more of us to be entrepreneurs and really be free
that's the goal and we can do it i really
like that i really appreciate that i think
your your passion for freedom and transparency is
totally aligned um you know with your with your
interest in decentralization and crypto so i'm
really excited to see what you do i really hope
you're able to um you know make some changes
and implement some positive changes as well
um where can people you know get involved in your
campaign how can people follow you um what yeah
plug yourself yeah yeah for sure morganharper.org
is our website on all social platforms mh408 so
mh number four oh and reach out let's stay in
touch and really appreciate everybody's support
we're in our final few weeks here may third's
our primary so it's uh it's game time for sure
well best of luck thank you so much for coming
on um you know and letting us know exactly
what's happening um and yeah i'll be following
thanks so much morgan thank you talk to you soon